hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the divided line
is a concept or better yet an analogy
that Plato provides us with at the very
end republic book 6 it's very famous
because it sets out in a sort of graphic
form that you can easily visualize how
all of the different modes of knowing
things and of proceeding and discussing
them and the things themselves how all
of those are related to each other in
Plato's metaphysics and his epistemology
that is in his understanding of how
things really are and in his
understanding or doctrine about how we
come to know things and what the various
modes of knowledge or just pretenders to
knowledge happen to be he begins by
having Socrates suggest that we think of
a line that is in some respects unevenly
divided and we could represent this in
whatever way we want to traditionally it
is represented with the visible side of
the line that is the part that pertains
to the visible world and our modes of
apprehension of those things of the
visible
world as getting the smaller part of the
line and then the intelligible world
which is not visible but as
understandable is grasped by our minds
gets a much larger part of the mind and
because Plato really does like
mathematics and and ratios he suggests
that the line should be divided first
into the two parts and then each of
those two parts should be similarly
divided along the same ratio between you
might say a higher better part and a
lower part now the line itself is in
some respects a continuum but in other
respects it represents a set of
intervals and what are we going from and
and to if we think about it in terms of
our own apprehension of things we might
depending on our level of development we
might not actually be able to grasp why
the things on the higher side of the
line are in fact clearer and more
understandable than the things on the
lower side of the line because we're
accustomed to them but if we actually
understood things correctly that is if
we had developed ourselves through the
sort of means that Plato suggests of
dialectic and actually studying
mathematics as well and contemplation
and divorcing ourselves from the
material visible realities
which aren't really realities for Plato
but merely copies of the truer realer
things if we've done that we would be
able to see that the things that fall on
the invisible immaterial
ideal side of the line actually do
possess a greater clarity and the things
on the other side of the line possess or
rather are possessed by or suffer and
unclarity a lack of being intelligible
and the stems from them
also not being truly what they put
themselves out as being not truly being
what they are so we've got this
fundamental division between the things
that are visible material the things
that are grasped by us through
perception about which we talk
constantly about which we form
conjectures but really we don't fully
know which include uh by the way our own
bodies although Plato doesn't mention
this here and then on the other side we
have the things of the intelligible
world so let's start with the interval
the shorter interval of the material
things Plato says we can divide this
into two sections and the first section
is that of images or shadows or
reflections and he talks about for
example reflections in water but also he
says reflections in hard surfaces so you
might think about a mirror for example
or you might think about when you're
looking at a piece of glass or burnished
metal or whatever else it is that you
might see your own reflection or the
reflection of other things within and
then he adds another key phrase there
that allows us to extend this to all
sorts of things including you watching
me in a video everything else of that
kind so images in general whether
they're paintings or print or video or
whatever you want to think of all of
that sort of stuff are within the realm
of images within the realm of copies
then we also have in the material world
what we're tempted to call real things
as opposed to the mirror images of them
Plato thinks that they're not really
real in the sense that the most real
things are but let's start where we are
so those would include he says animals
that includes
right we're among the animals plants and
then he talks about everything that is
made by human beings so we can call
those artifacts if you like houses if
you live in a city like I do you're
constantly surrounded by things that are
artifacts this chalkboard that I'm using
to depict things is an artifact as is
the camera and the recording devices I'm
using my tie my shirt
pretty much everything that we can
encounter is either natural or it's
human-made and all these are visible
well some may be less visible than
others the wind for example but it is
material right and these things are in
some respect more real more true they
have a certain being and the copies of
them have less and the copies refer to
the the material things right you see an
image of a dog well there has to be a
dog or even when we put things together
like a unicorn perhaps there were
unicorns at one time but there certainly
aren't any now as far as we know we take
the idea of a horse and then we take a
horn plunk it on top and if we want to
add in other things about you know is
fierce to everybody but versions well
that's that's just stuff that we're
tacking on to it and we're trying to
create something that that's like a copy
of a non-existent material thing but if
it did exist it would exist as a
material thing that's that side of the
line when we move to the other side of
the line things are a little less clear
in the dialogue and Socrates has to do a
bit more explaining some of which is
going to bring in some discussion of the
geometric arts or Sciences and we'll go
to that in a moment we have on this side
some things that do qualify as forms or
ideas
a day or ETA right in in plato's terms
and those are not material those don't
exist in the same sense that material
objects do so if we think for example
about the circle right draw a circle on
a chalkboard
that's a circle drawn in chalk and it's
never a perfect circle right
everything that's material is in some
way not quite what the ideal is and the
ideal is a perfect circle that is the
pattern or archetype or idea of those
and many people would say well that's
just a concept that you've put together
in your mind sort of idealizing away
from the real circles that you've seen
but with Plato it's actually the
opposite the material things that we're
tempted to call real existing things are
really just copies of the ideal the
ideal is more real than the material
things are so the ideal circle is more
real than all the circles that you can
draw whether in sand or chalk or
charcoal or engraving on stone or metal
whatever circles you make out of rope or
wood or anything else that you pick you
make a circle with your arms that's not
as real as the circle that it derives
from and in a certain way you can say
well just as the images here are copies
of the material things the material
things are merely copies of those things
and we might include other forms in
there as well although Plato doesn't say
it at this point when you know he talks
about the form of the bed for example or
we might think of a form of a chair or
other objects like that perhaps those
forms are actually at this part of the
line and they're grasped in the way that
things in that part of the line are
finally the
that are actually most real true
intelligible understandable those are
the forms or ideas themselves not
understood in reference or by means of
images or copies or anything like that
but understood in their own right and
this includes the form of the good or as
Plato is calling it here in this section
the good itself
Haga thrown out toasts right the thing
that is the good which is in a certain
way is a form that gives the other forms
their being and and their goodness and
all of those other things that we don't
have to go too deep into that right
right now so we've got all of these
different things and what else we didn't
need to say about this side the
intelligible side of the line is that
Plato thinks that the ways in which we
are grasping the forms for example of
mathematical objects or embeds you know
that we think are the real bed as
opposed to the copies that the carpenter
makes or the images or anything like
that these are all grasped in a certain
conditioned manner he talks about
grasping them by means of hypotheses or
assumptions so we're not grasping the
thing as such what what is most real in
its own right we're grasping it in a way
by ascending from the images and the
material things to those forms there's
nothing wrong with that but we just
shouldn't assume that that is the end of
the story because what gets us to the
end of the story is as he says the use
of dialectic which allows us to move
past these assumptions or if you want to
think about it in another way he's got a
really wonderful
way of speaking about it here he says we
mean to distinguish the aspect of
reality and the intelligible which is
contemplated by the power of dialectic
as something truer and more exact than
the object of the so-called Arts and
Sciences whose assumptions are arbitrary
starting points and he says it is true
that those who contemplate them meaning
that the objects of dialectic are
compelled to use their understanding and
out their senses yet because they do not
go back to the beginning of the study
but start from assumptions they do not
think they possess true intelligence
about them but what can they do they can
he says
lay hold by the power of dialectic on
these things treating its assumptions
not as an absolute beginnings but rather
as underpinnings footing springboards
that allow them to move beyond just
these hypotheses what he's talking about
there is a sort of unconditioned science
that will eventually come to be called
metaphysics Plato is not using that term
that comes into origin with Aristotle
but that is really what he's talking
about now the other thing that's really
important here is thinking about the
modes of knowledge or facsimile of
knowledge if you like or pseudo
knowledge that our minds or our souls
employ in grasping these things again
let's start at the low end of the scale
and Plato uses certain Greek terms that
are and some some of them are easy to
translate others are not quite so easy
to translate it cassia comes from the
word a con all right image and the idea
here is that we grasp these shadows
reflections copies of copies images all
those sorts of things
through a cassia and a cassia you could
call it it's been translated as
imagination or a mad
it's also been translated as picture
thinking what you're doing is you're
grasping the pictures themselves and you
take those as if they're real things
even though they're they're not actually
real they're merely copies and this
falls in the realm of opinion or Doak
son not real knowledge it's things that
we could actually be right about but if
we do happen to be right it's not
because we possess genuine knowledge
it's because we got lucky or we have a
certain knack for getting things right
in those ways and even when we move to
the realm of the material objects we're
still dealing with the realm of opinion
here eros here at Plato uses the term
pista s' which we can easily translate
as belief later on in other authors that
will come to mean faith can also mean a
certain sort of credence these are all
really synonyms for each other trusts is
another way of understanding it it's not
knowledge it's not really grasping the
things as such but being able to sort of
negotiate our way around with them once
we start moving past that for Plato into
the realm of the intelligible we start
to make more progress in terms of using
higher parts of our mind and we have the
possibility of genuine knowledge Plato
is going to divide this into two
different sorts here and there's
different ways of translating these
there aren't any really great English
translations for these terms but we can
talk about what the functional
difference is da Noya is the lower form
and this is a sort of discursive still
using images and hypotheses way of
grasping things but it is a true grasp
of those things so the person who is
doing geometry and has managed to move
past looking at a circle on a page or
triangles or whatever it happens to be
that's being discussed and to
conceptualize the principles involved
the things themselves the the forms as
Plato would say they are they do have
genuine knowledge geometry is a real
science and we could say similar things
about others as well even the doctor who
is beginning with bodies but is
conceptualizing how they work and
grasping them's in terms of their forms
Plato does think that medicine is a form
of science or techne right they are
using DNA
they are using what we might call
understanding or reasoning or discursive
thinking when we move past that when we
move higher than that when we are
grappling with the ideas themselves when
we're engaged in contemplation of them
and using dialectic then we are doing no
ASIS or we are you might say no ASIS
right and this is the highest capacity
of a human being so no ASIS it's
translated in some places as reason
that's probably a bit misleading
understanding is another way
intellection I do want to resist the the
notion that we can associate this with a
purely intuitive grasp of things because
dialectic itself is not simply intuitive
in the sense of like a gut feeling right
although that would actually be down at
the other end but you could think of it
if you want to think of it as intuition
it would be the kind of intuition you
would have to work really hard through
first of all discursive means to get to
and then you would finally enjoy and it
would not be something that you could
you know reach by some sort of leap
skipping all the work involved
now to bring this to a close one of the
things that Plato is telling us here is
that we move from these lower ends of
the line into the intelligible
non-material region by means of using
those images the material things which
are images of the forms and the images
of the images and one of the things that
you should think over and I'm just going
to leave this as something to meditate
upon is well what is this analogy or
metaphor of the divided line itself it
is indeed something that is being
represented in speech and of which we
can produce a sort of schema or image
are we ourselves doing precisely the
sort of thing at least on a lower scale
that Plato him himself has outlined for
us in terms of the divided line is it
possible that some people might grasp
the divided line solely as an image and
others might go beyond that and use it
as a means to approach and then finally
to be in communication with what Plato
calls the forms I leave that to you as
an open question what do you make of the
divided line
you